finally we can start writing the page
but before we do we need some kind of
convention for how we're going to name
all of the columns in our grid so we can
easily remember them later when we want
to use them first off we need a name for
this entire row and for that I think it
makes sense to just call it a row no
need to make things complicated now we
need names for all of the columns here
or for our elements of different column
widths first one will do well column 1
why not
it's one column wide so we'll just call
it column 1 if we want element to be two
columns wide we'll call it column - two
to indicate that it's two columns wide
same thing for column three that is
three columns wide and so on until we
get to column twelve which is the full
width of the row
this makes our lives pretty easy let's
imagine we wanted something to be a
quarter of the full width wide a quarter
of twelve is three so we simply need to
give that element a class of column
three to make sure it's a quarter of
this entire row let's go ahead and set
this up in our CSS file first we'll set
up some borders so we can easily see
where our elements are on the screen and
then let's set up some box sizing then
we'll define our row remember each row
should take up the entire width of the
screen so we'll set it to width 100%
after row we'll set up the width of all
of our columns you'll see column one
column two column three
just like we decided to do before and
each width is set to a percentage of the
page column one is one twelfth of the
page column two is two twelfths of the
page column three is three twelfth of
the page and so on now that we've got
our CSS set let's get a sample page to
see if this works in the instructor
notes you'll find the HTML that you see
right here notice that we've got an
outer class of row and then two inner
columns column two and column ten so
together they should fill up the entire
row then we have column 3 column nine 3
plus 9 is 12 so these two columns should
also fill up this row let's see if it
works
opening test HTML and the browser and we
see this hmm something doesn't look
right so we can see column two and
column 10 but it looks like they're
stacked on top of each other they're not
lining up next to each other
same thing 4 3 & 9 3 fours 3 6 3 each
one of these should just fill up one row
but instead the columns are stacked on
top of each other it looks like we've
got a problem here
what style should we add to
rogue classes CSS to fix the way the
columns are behaving should we add
display:block
should we add display flex and flex wrap
wrap or just display float the easiest
way to figure this out is to open up dev
tools and add these CSS styles to the
row class